so the against gm not
from the usa for example but from germany
for a double in many cities
so one of the many
possible positions in symmetrical
english is
actually a normal, very pleasant
variant
where white has a bit of an advantage
i have now
unfortunately
drawn 2
and financed a bit early  therefore now allowed here at 5 that was of
course not wanted too
bad
that's unpleasantly
good because I'm gone
so I have to now also
could have jumper I could draw here
just hear me an ok yes times with that
very 1
so
I now jump the four games
or sport c3 jumper the 5 yes that
's a bit cramped
b5 of course you shouldn't actually
allow it in the position
so maybe it makes sense
to simplify here a little
he he can play like four
that's not
could jumper himself at  Playing four
and blocking it
doesn't do any good either
because it's not quite as accurate as how horrible
it is  if he really does that
if you now it wouldn't have worked at all
not exactly as if it
fits to the previous
distressed ones
I actually thought I could
hit the six now
or did he then at some point kick
jump springer the four-  or so
i don't see it
the finished lady 5 at least
yes i don't know what he's going to play now he
's ok den or done so that the
question
whether i might have something
better here he pulled to draw he
has no deduction good 8  or something like that
isn't exactly threatening in any way so
the whole thing brought in a smooth pawn
so stinner queen e3
yes if he
doesn't take it so clearly now
maybe he can take the four with the pawn knight
although it's not entirely clear she's dangerous
in the move  because he looks
unpleasant by heart so I suppose has
around 2
maybe
because I have the field here with
the pawn
and I was as usual l of clubs  angsam good
i don't want to miss the opportunity to add another jumper
so you
have c6 now you are
swapping twice in the endgame with two more points
it was seen earlier but at the
time you could have stirred things up a bit
but you should have  relatively
easy to win because I still have
the tower on the exit, the square is
right for the pawn and he
can't somehow come in on the second row
, you have the finish line
, it
should be relatively easy to win